this is a after a fire fight we're doing
four day mission closing fobs in the
valley just got hit it was a aftermath
of a firefighter it took me ten years to
be able to okay and look at it I don't
know it's a memory I went through it
reminds me who I am and what I've done
22 veterans per day commit suicide most
of the population don't understand what
the symptoms are they don't understand
that this is just not an angry person
this is somebody has been truly damaged
by war I come from a long line of
military my family was all military our
son had joined the United States Air
Force and in 2006 he passed away and
that was the segue into finding more
purpose really I think a lot of things
his personal relationships I went back
to school in 2007 to get my psychology
degree and I stumbled upon equine
assisted psychotherapy nothing makes me
feel alive like combat did I missed that
bond when you trust someone in those
parameters it's hard to trust someone in
a different setting it's not like they
the show in the movies
we're not psychotic animals we want
peace above anything anywhere I would
try to get help that is for veterans
they shut me out they kicked me out
deal with it I was on a pure path of
destruction
go back go back we use the horses as
metaphors they are eleven hundred pound
animals so the veteran has to work out
how to get the horse to want to go with
them and they start to see how their
behaviors have affected their family
members or those around them Dennis was
in a really dark place I heard about the
ranch I was like let's let's just try it
let's see what we can do he is a Purple
Heart recipient along with many other
medals but it took him a good six months
before he could even really start to
talk to me so we had to go very very
carefully and very slowly I can't
communicate well with human beings I'm
strange I'm awkward and weird don't care
who I am it's a matter of respect of
like with an animal words no need to be
said to express who you are
coming out here he's not thinking about
all those other things that are always
going on like tornadoes in his head it's
good for him knowing that another life
depends on him normal life to me it
would look like the house have some kids
and it's difficult and it shouldn't be
that way I think real estate really
trained me to deal with many many
different types of people in particular
working with the veterans
it's got unique challenges and I
personally feel that we owe our veterans
somewhere that they can feel safe when
they come back from war that's what the
ranch does it makes them feel safe back
home again and to move forward into
somewhat of a new normal in life Dennis
is such a unique person such a loyal
person and that's something so it's
something so hard to find in people
if you're a veteran this is a place to
feel at home and feel safe and feel like
you won't be judged and made me a better
person he can completely
you